always the first one's the weirdest yep
always real quick but for now i'm like
i'm sitting on the wrong side i feel like
i'm in europe and i'm driving the car wrong
what's going on there reject nation so we're
going to be doing something different we're
introducing a new segment to the channel called
koi's comic corner graphics to come later
implied visuals cartoon koi there so yeah we've
been trying to find a segment for koi to do here
uh on the channel that's specifically suited for
him yeah there's gonna be times where neither
myself nor john are in the video because you'll
see how we might be rendered pointless after a
while i'm gonna hand this off to koi today i
thought it would be fun for you to kick off
your first segment with how the fantastic four
will be introduced into the mcu take it away
koi gendro so i'm thinking we're gonna talk
about the last time we saw the fantastic four
how i would introduce them into this universe
who i might cast some suggested reading and
even some plot details of where i think the mcu
could bring the fantastic four marvel's first
family feels like a good place to start with a
first episode of this show it feels very good
because this is something we've been striving
for since the mcu began and arguably it's one
of the first mainstream teams that the people
were aware of this came out not long after
x-men it was not long after spider-man but it's
a coy for your first segment please don't smack
the microphone i feel like it's needed i feel
like i gotta show it i'm laying the president
i'm an alpha male i'll give you something it's
like prison you gotta beat up the biggest guy in
the room so i feel like with the precedent set by
obviously multiverse of madness we will be seeing
them sooner than later i also feel like it's
not a coincidence that they moved quantum mania
up because i do feel like we're getting
not only kang thing look who did it
i love that i saw peripherally and i just felt the
connection but i feel like after uh quantomania
we're gonna be in a very different world of the
mcu i saw the video you made about how it's insane
that people think that this is directionless
it's not phase four is not directionless what's
going to happen is much like civil war i think
after quantum mania there's going to be a big
pivot into where phase 4 is going i think it's
very intentionally open-ended right now just
like phase one started we're only five movies into
phase four i think the big turn is going to be in
ant-manimos quantomania i think that's going to
yield a fantastic four if not all of them some
of them and i think we are gonna get at least nods
to dr doom and black panther so i'd say by the end
of the year more fantastic four by the end of next
year all but established just in time for 2024's
fantastic four but how are they being introduced
i feel like the way to do it is in ant-man and the
wasp you've got the quantum realm which is very
well established and if you've seen a lot of those
theories there's a small city a la superman small
city in a bottle you've got this tiny little city
i feel like the best way to show the fantastic
four's intelligence is to have them preserved
in time i would have them trapped in time a la
janet van dyne and have their technology still
advanced from today's technology imagine a man
so intelligent that what he was inventing in the
60s is available now that's how you don't have
yet another kind of aloof an overly intelligent
character if you've got doctor strange and iron
man feeling like each other the last thing you
want is another guy that's like i'm a bit hard to
deal with and very smart you do that by having a
fish out of water story you have the marvel's
first family be something from the 60s you have
it feel like this weird throwback to a bygone
era and that also differentiates it from a lot
of other marvel team books because you've got the
avengers already well established you've got young
avengers to come you've got the x-men to come how
do you make marvel's first family feel different
you set them as a fish out of water story and you
make the family dynamic what brings them closer
together they're the only people from this time
they're stuck together and that's also a big part
of the comic books is johnny can turn his flames
on and off but the thing is stuck as the thing
one of them is a movie star effectively one of
them's a monster but they're all bonded together
by this family element that they're adventurers
add to that the 60s element add to that being
trapped together i think it adds another dynamic
to an already incredible story and in addition to
all the 60s stuff of having them be fish out
of water there was that really subtle drop
that really got overshadowed by everyone cheering
in the movie where doctor strange actually says
didn't you chart in the 60s which is either a boy
band joke or actually is acknowledging that reed
richards was from the 60s so we might already have
them be canon in our universe by doctor strange at
least knowing and acknowledging who he is they
could play that either way which is fun about
easter eggs is they could never acknowledge that
again it could be a joke or it could be the 60s
concept of having krazynski's reed richards
already established which would make that
krazynski canon because doctor strange wouldn't
be like hey there's this guy that vaguely looks
like a stretchy dude i bet that's reid like you
have to be john krasinski for that joke to work
and there's a lot of rumors that john mayer may
not come back so that would kind of make it for
the plot of your fantastic four movie or the idea
initially upon introduction is that they've been
trapped in the quantum realm so are you suggesting
that their first movie would be about them in the
60s prior to them getting trapped similar to
the way how captain america first avenger was
about him in the 40s and then it ended with him
getting trapped in the ice yeah in the same vein
we've had 40s and 90s with captain marvel i'd
have 60s with fantastic four i would throw back
modern day and past tens i would use a nihilist
personally we haven't seen annihilus on screen
what is a nihilism annihilus is a devourer of
basically content but nihilus consumes all not
quite to the level of galactus where it gives
energy but annihilus is a negative zone villain
that is all-consuming all corrupting and it looks
like a giant insect imagine a very very evil
cricket it looks like an evil green and purple
cricket and i think that villain since we haven't
seen it on screen before and it's kind of not one
note i feel like one note's not fair but simple
it's a simple villain so you wouldn't have to do
a lot of backstory you could really dive into the
family and then allow this villain to build up
and earn doctor doom i don't think dr dunes be
the main villain for the first film i think it
should be kind of the emperor palpatine use the
nihilist to give us some story and i would sub
the negative zone concept for the quantum realm
and then it's kind of plug and play you just
swap out the term negative zone for quantum
realm which is already established and you got
yourself a movie i think i know what lost city
you're talking about i've heard a lot of people
theorizing that's king's castle i think it can
be king's castle that they're trapped oh right
so therefore you've got king as something that's
been corrupting them from the beginning you've
got kang as a very doctor doom-esque element and
i love the idea that kang grandfather to reed
richards in many continuities would be the one
keeping them trapped so yeah we've already
met kang that would endear us to them more
and if you do want to keep john krasinski you
could have kang be the father of sue storm
instead of reed richards that way you still get
the family element and that way you have one of
those twists that marvel likes to do where it's
a twist on comic book fans expectations it's a
little nudge but then the people in the audience
if they don't know are like oh my god the dad
of like star wars and the people that do know are
like wait that's not the father and it'd be really
fun to play with we can't reasonably have john
krasinski be the grandson of kang as it stands
now but we could do that with sue okay i know you
mentioned krasinski what would the cast of this
be so in the comics kang is is often nathaniel
richards who is a time traveler who's related to
reed richards so the twist would be sue storm and
in some relation whether father grandfather you
could do anything with time travel we haven't met
kang yet we've met he who remains so we've got an
infinite number of possibilities and i do honestly
think kang is going to be bigger than thanos
i think we're going to see at least 10 kangs
throughout these movies and we're going to get
to see the incredible performances of variations
of kang we met the one who was a bit altruistic
while still a villain with that shakespearean
goodness so what i would do is if we go with kang
being the twist related to sue storm i'd love to
see someone like alexis louder who's in cop shop
who is my dreamcast for storm but i i think she's
very capable she's got an intelligence tour she's
got this whip smart attitude that i think needs
to keep up with read the beautiful thing about
reed and sue is that reed is the most intelligent
man on the planet and sue keeps up and is often
smarter because she's got street smarts that reed
doesn't have so just because he's the smartest man
on the planet doesn't mean you know sue's in the
kitchen she's an incredibly smart woman who also
is able to fight who navigates family arguably
she's the thing that keeps them all together and
you need someone that shows profound intelligence
capability all of those things and i think alexis
louder is absolutely that if you do the thing
everyone wants as far as the cliche obviously
emily blunt like emily blunt and john krzezinski
that might be the only way we get emily blunt in
the mcu still he's the daughter of king still the
daughter he's still the dark how we'll figure it
out but if john krasinski does end up directing
then you have the quiet place situation an entire
family dynamic already built in and they seem
obviously like a couple but they're also very
paternal and maternal so that would add a lot
of good elements to eventually having franklin
richards eventually growing out the family and i
could easily see emily blunt having to deal with
a zac efron or jacob montgomery uh human torch
there's also what's a homeboy from um blond dude
really pretty always pops up he's in game night
um he's got like piercing blue eyes he's kind
of snarky but he plays a villain sometimes
his imdb isn't up here but his name is not
that guy i would also it's just a graphic just
somebody put up a graphic so i can be shaped
into this later he'd be a great human torch as
well but you need human torch to be someone who
he's a hothead but he has to grow you need his
ark to develop what you love about human torch
is that he's your eye line into the fantastic four
because everyone wants to be cool but he actually
matures as a person throughout the journey he's
kind of like the anti-peter parker peter parker
puts on his mask and gets confidence human torch
d flames and learns to grow so his confidence is
real instead of fake like his confidence is hot
air and therefore he has to grow as a person to
be confident for real so i'd love to see someone
with some depth that seems like they're just
on the surface which is why dr montgomery is so
great because that dude played such a good villain
he was so interesting did i yeah yeah there it
is it's just stranger things from yeah but i was
talking about three i gave three there's one more
guy that i can't think of yeah i'll make myself
use what's his name by looking up from everyone
how do you keep talking coins okay so finally
i would say the great joel edgerton as the thing
i think joel edgerton he's got a soft compassion
about him but also when he's angry you feel
through that i think his eyes are really gentle
which really need to be for the thing yeah billy
magnussen how good of a human torch would he be
uh he'd be great if i remembered anything he did
but yeah he'd be perfect magnusson heard some such
things greg's seen as igb and other movies and
then joel edgerton as thing he's got the build
for it he's got that new york attitude when he
wants to the soft gentle eyes juxtaposing the
orange rock facade very important you also want
to feel compassion for him when he's like reed
you did this to me i'm stuck like this and i think
joel edgerton has so much heart on his sleeve that
you'll feel that heart through the rocky exterior
and we obviously need to talk about doctor doom
but as i think he's going to be introduced
in black panther i want to wrap around the
idea of more of a political figure ambassador how
they're going to lay that out so that's going to
be a whole separate video because i do have some
ideas of how doctor doom specifically ties into
black panther and some casting ideas way to tease
a false video it's a pilot ladies and gentlemen
got in on a cliffhanger with a pilot i
watch tv recommend some reading material
i got you in modern continuity one of my favorite
runs of all time is mark wade and mike ringo this
is a run that lasts years it is dozens and dozens
of issues and mike ringo to me is one of the best
artists that's ever worked on fantastic four cause
his energy in his frames are so kinetic they're so
high energy it's almost uh surrealistic to the
level of cartoony it's almost like a saturday
morning cartoon but it's more photo realistic
than saturday morning cartoons that actually
ties really well into that 60s concept i'd
also say the current run by dan slott what
he's doing with fantastic four some of his best
work it gives you a lot more franklin richards it
gives you a lot more the family dynamic it plays
around with human torch as someone that's trapped
as the torch he can't deflame right now and
there's some really interesting doctor doom
stuff and of course i would recommend going back
to the very beginning i think going back to the
source material uh mole man introduction all
the way back to the jump fantastic four came
out in the early 60s this predates most comic
books if you look at modern comic books they
owe a lot to the fantastic four so i would say
going back to stan lee's original fantastic four
number one which you can read digitally they've
re-mastered it a number of time picking up one of
those big essential novels is absolutely a good
time and if you don't find that as approachable
the ultimate stuff i think is where we're
eventually going ultimate fantastic four
original stan lee fantastic four most recommended
as mark wade and mike ringo as well as the current
dan slot run is what i would recommend there's
a lot of other stuff but again we'll talk about
that more when it pertains specifically to other
videos and ideas wow comics so the next video i'm
i'm just going to be off to the side hey you
told me who billy magnuson was ask talk about
this what about comics i was going to get stuck
who would play john malkovich or i'm just going
to create a split screen and loot me nodding oh
yeah that's good stop hitting the mic just like
you have little signs you hold up little flags all
right guys well here's what we can do why don't
you go ahead and suggest some topics that maybe
koi can cover as we're finessing this eventually
it'll just be him on camera holding the fort
down we'll see how the moment john goes we'll see
like maybe not like this one went one way this is
actually better too maybe maybe people need coins
person not we'll see you guys subscribe
let's catch you soon it's good to be here